[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
i'm ken coleman ramsey personality host
of the ken coleman show on the ramsey
network joined by my colleague
dr john deloney who is host of the dr
john daloni show a ramsey personality as
well
and we are here to take your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five it is a toll-free
number triple eight
eight two five five two two five now of
course you're familiar with the ramsey
show and talking money
uh but we're gonna talk about more than
money
we'll talk about dr john's expertise
mental and emotional health
uh we'll talk about your work situation
do you want to make some more money do
you want to switch jobs you have a toxic
work environment oh
john and i'll team up on that and so
what we need to do is
figure out what you need and then we
work together
to give you some practical advice john
good to be with you as always
you too man and thank you for reminding
me to
even turn my microphone on yeah yeah i
was looking over there because i thought
at any moment
you're going to jump in and the mic's
not going to be on but that's what we do
for each other it's
well here's what we do um they bring me
in who's a hack
and next to a professional radio guy and
it works out really well for everybody
we have fun
especially the listener and we love to
help people that's right so john and i
are going to team up so again we'll take
your normal money calls
but john and i really do enjoy taking on
the especially when we've got
yucky work stuff cause i'll talk to you
about the tactical and some of the
some of the hey what what's my zone my
country but there's all this other
mental and emotional junk there john
it's all and we like to team up on those
so it looks like we might have one of
those to get started let's go to mobile
alabama where ricky is on the line ricky
how can we help
hey man how y'all doing uh thank you all
for taking my call you bet what's going
on with you
uh well i'm having a little trouble uh
believing in myself jumping off into a
new career path
and uh i'm just i'm scared to take the
leap
i've um i work i work at a alabama power
plant
and i work seven days straight and then
i'm off seven days and
i've uh i recently acquired my life and
health
insurance license here in alabama and i
want to
i want to do that full time i'm an
independent broker i have contracts with
all the major carriers and i want to do
that full-time
and i'm just i'm i'm a little bit
nervous about going to a
strictly commission based income from my
steady income now makes total sense i'm
going to have john jump in on
on some of that fear stuff because he
really is an expert but i do want to
talk tactically too this is
this hey ricky i was i'll tell you this
about fear this is about tactics brother
you
you've you've walked through you've got
the license you've gotten the
connections these contracts you're
you're into the fear part now it's just
about tactics and math
yeah so so so ricky here's the deal um
it's a straight commission deal are you
going to be truly out on your own under
another broker is that what that means
so if you were to go into this which i'm
not going to tell you to do to just drop
everything and go into this unless we've
got the financial wherewithal to do it
but if you did that it's just you and
you're out there beating the pavement in
mobile alabama
trying to get people to buy their
insurance through you is that how this
is going to be set up
yes sir okay great how much do you make
right now in your power
the alabama power job uh last year i
grossed
fifty nine thousand fifty nine thousand
do you have any debt
i have two two vehicles i owe less than
um less than nine thousand dollars on
together okay that's it all right and so
you're are you
on the baby steps now so you're in baby
step two knocking those two out
yes sir okay great and so you know baby
step three is we gotta get that
three to six months emergency fund in
place uh
so right now you're in a financial
situation where
you can't just take a leap you could but
i don't think it's wise for you to go to
a straight commission leap right now
and that's what you're feeling correct
right
right and and the thing uh the way my
work schedule is
with working seven days at the plan and
having seven full days off
i've been able to uh i've been able to
to work
both that's where we were going ricky
yeah you're way ahead
you're already ahead of me but i wanted
to walk you through you're afraid of
something you don't need to be afraid of
so here's my point because you got this
great job that's seven days on seven
days off
you're building the insurance business
on the seven days that you're off
and you're not losing any progress on
the debt free snowball journey
and then the three months expenses or
six months expenses there's actually
nothing to be afraid of this is
perfect you actually have a full-time
job that allows you
a full week in between your week of
working
to actually pursue the dream job so go
after it you have nothing to lose so you
have nothing to be afraid of john that's
where i've taken him so ricky here's the
hard part i'm going to tell you about a
conversation i had with my boss
this morning uh-oh and it's it's
something that i'm terrible at
and that my guess is you're gonna have
to learn how to do hold on one second
james can we get somebody from hr in
here
we don't know where this is going we've
had it hey ricky here it is
you're gonna have to be patient oh okay
we can yeah that's good that's good
you're gonna have to be patient you're a
go-getter yep you are somebody who
rocks and rolls and gets it done you run
a power plant you're the man
you make good money you're crushing
through these things i bet you're a fun
guy to hang out with
and then you decided i'm gonna go be a
broker i'm gonna build stuff up
and now you're gonna have to do the slog
grindy
turtle versus the hair work of just
showing up
week after week you're gonna be
exhausted from your seven days on
you have to get up and make those phone
calls get up and do those things
you have to email those people back and
have call after call after call where
you make no sale no sale or no sale
you just have to be patient that's it
all right and that sucks it's not fun
and it's a hundred percent part of this
deal
but ricky when you replace
the 59 000 so you've got that insurance
business up to where it's bringing in
your monthly equal to your 59 000
job right now then you can tell the
power job by felicia
right but until then you stay with this
and then there is zero risk financially
thus nothing for you to be afraid of the
monster that you think is under the bed
is not under the bed that's right so
that's how we do it now to your point
john it's gotta be patient
that's tough cause what happens is he
starts getting those first couple
insurance clients i'm out of here oh i
love this he's like i don't want to go
to the power play for seven days
here's what's gonna happen he's gonna
land three new clients in one week
right and then tuesday of that following
week at the plant he's going to get
called in he's going to get ringed out
for not filling out a tps report though
right away or harold the jerk
comes in and throws his lunch box on the
ground spills coffee he's like this guy
he's an idiot he talks politics all the
time i can't
deal with this one more day and the
answer is you can't you have to you got
to keep going
because on the other side of all that
slog
he's working for himself your own boss
hey yeah
ricky three years from now
you're gonna be on vacation with your
family
at the beach come out of the ocean dry
off lay under the thing pick up your
phone
and go oh just made some money while i
was flopping around in the ocean
am i right yeah so so and i'm having
some fun with this folks but i want you
to get this
that's the vision you hold on to during
the slog that's right
i'm doing what i have to do so that i
can do what i want to do
that's right and again this applies with
marriage i want to just
pop back off with this conversation well
that's a true don't be patient
it's with getting in shape yeah like i
want to work have a hard week of
workouts and just
look in the mirror and be like what's up
yeah that's not how that works
yeah we go to the gym for an hour we go
to the bathroom we start looking at our
waistline
it's like what happened wait it's not it
didn't shrink yeah let's keep going yeah
got to keep going we do that with our
spiritual walk everything
is about showing up and showing up about
patience right about being patient
and then you're right three years from
now walking out of the beach oh yeah
all right cash registers that's right
it's gonna be a good
christmas mama
that's the my times hey it's worth it
stay with it keep the eye on the prize
don't move more ramsay show coming right
[Music]
up
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure talk just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show thrilled
to have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
dr john deloney and we are here taking
your calls
aaa 825-5225 is the number triple eight
eight two five five two two five i've
heard countless stories i know you have
two from people who've lost a loved one
and were totally shocked
when they reviewed the will your final
wishes
should not be a surprise people when you
leave your family in the dark you're
setting
up for huge problems down the road so
make sure that you talk to them about
your end-of-life plans
the how to talk about your legacy guide
by the way john
really good job on whoever wrote that
because if it said how to talk about
your death guide
yeah not great nobody wants to download
legacy legacy is much
kinder much nicer the how to talk about
your legacy guide will help you have the
right conversations before
and after making a will it's going to
teach you how to specifically plan your
conversations
get on the same page with your spouse
ask people to be your executor kids
guardian or
power of attorney and tell the rest of
the family what's in the will
now you can give your family peace of
mind because there won't be any
unpleasant surprises
after you're gone text the word legacy
to 33789 to get your free how to talk
about your legacy guide today again text
the word legacy
to three three seven eight
nine triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number let's go to
indianapolis indiana
where james joins us james how can we
help
yeah i was um i have a 401k that
i just has a little bit into it and we
have
probably like nine uh 7 900 left on our
consumer debt
my thought was to take that out and just
pay that off take it out early
and pay off my consumer debt and then
start with the rest of the baby steps
no you should not do that you're so
close man i know it's so tempting
yeah how much have you paid off uh
we've paid off let's see
five and then carry the one
yeah i know about 15 000. yeah good job
what's your payoff day
um it's gonna be mid next year yeah
here's the deal you've got to be patient
you guys have done so much that 7 900
could probably be paid off closer sooner
if you get really really creative on how
you could do that and i love the idea
this came from creativity right but we
always say no to this question we'll
always say no because you're going to
take a tax hit
on this when you pull that money out and
it's an unnecessary tax hit
that money is stay in your 401k and grow
you guys can knock that 7 900 out
probably quicker than you think and even
if you can't
you're still going to get it you're so
close don't make a bad financial
decision
okay to try to make a good one you end
up
borrowing from your future self yeah to
pay back something that your past self
did don't do that to yourself
right hey let me ask you this james if
you went berserker mode
and just swallowed every last little
indianapolis ego pride you had
could you go get a job delivering pizzas
or drive an uber and just
crush this thing and pay it off
yes yeah yeah hey
i want to tell you we talked to
thousands and millions of people who pay
off debt
i want you to know that you think you
know how good it's going to be on the
other side you don't
until you experience it and when you do
you'll go oh
i should have got here faster dude
you're you are worth going berserker
mode and getting this thing done
do it do it do it don't shortcut it
don't borrow from yourself from your
future self
just go get another job and get it done
absolutely thank you for the call james
matthew joins us next in orlando florida
matthew how can we help
hey guys thank you for taking my call
you bet what's going on
so i'm 22 years old about to graduate
from college debt free
i have a job lined up in a couple of
weeks where i'm going to be starting
i'm about to start baby step four and
i'm looking at getting a new
car so i'm going to be getting a signing
bonus
from my upcoming job and between that
and my tax return
i feel like i'm going to be able to put
together a lot of money towards a car
how much i'm wondering is bro i'm
looking at
about 10 000 towards a car
and then i'm looking at
potentially even going up higher to
closer to 15
000 but reducing from six months to
three months expenses in my uh
purchasing fund
i was wondering if you guys thought that
would be an okay thing to do if i wanted
to knock it down
to three months or if i should keep it
at six months
well bottom line is if you look at what
we teach we say three
to six months so you know uh are you
breaking some
rule no i just wouldn't do it you've
worked so hard to get
six months expenses that's a really good
night's sleep
and you got 10k this is all this is all
as soon as you start the new job
and you're graduating college debt-free
so we're only talking about
three four months of just super
disciplined young single guy
saving up the extra five so the answer
is no i would not do that
matt my wife has driven a car that we
bought for ten thousand dollars for the
last four or five years i think with our
two kids in it the car i bought i really
went all in
and mine was 16. now listen
there's nothing wrong with buying nice
cars and one day i hope to
but i haven't felt a good enough
financial position to just go blow a
bunch of money
on cars is your first gig you need to
get
uh buy ten thousand dollar car man be
super happy with it and just be about
saving that money up ken
made what i think is the most underrated
component to your health ken just called
it out it's a good night's sleep
and you're going to get into your new
job and you're going to think this is
this boss is terrible
i don't want to be here i fill in the
blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank
and you will have nothing to worry about
you got six months emergency fund a ten
thousand dollar
is gonna get you ready to go your
options will literally be limitless
because you didn't go overboard now
anything if you had twenty five thousand
bucks in cash and somebody who should
buy cars that bad no
it's not i'm just telling you my own
house we i don't think it's that big of
a deal right i did do this
i went and bought a big new fancy truck
car a truck when i graduated college
for my first job that was the stupidest
dumbest
because i had to have it can i want to
be so cool yeah didn't need it man yeah
matthew get a ten thousand dollar car
and ride out man call it good yeah yeah
i mean you got a couple options there
you know you're gonna have a really good
job do not touch the emergency fund
that's why we call it an emergency fund
and uh you do not have an emergency but
uh congratulations
uh let's not move over the fact that
this young man for whatever reason
it's incredible he's graduating college
debt free that makes him a
um unicorn yes and all by himself that's
right
and and i think that's right i think you
know this this delay this delayed
gratification
on things that you can make a good case
for are the toughest ones to deal with
like this because he can make a case
well i could still have a three-month
emergency fund and he laid it out for us
and and and that's what
that's the kind of stuff that that kills
your progress that's right
and man i feel like this is a common
theme already in this hour
it's just about being patient right it's
just about being patient and patient and
patient
buy buy the a car that's gonna get you
to and from you're 23 years old you have
nothing to prove to anybody
get where you need to go and then head
on back yeah you know let's talk about
this for a second because
you've been talking about patience and
patience and get staying with it and i
will tell you in my
own journey so i'm just speaking for me
here
you can psychoanalyze me my friend the
greatest tension that i have faced in my
professional life
and then i'm starting to see it now as a
parent with teens
the greatest tension i deal with is
the tension between persistence and
patience i got to get up and do the
right thing in my work
i got to get up and pay my dues learn
how to do radio right learn how to write
books
all the things that you and i do
professionally right how do we help
people better yeah
we always wanted to help more people so
you and i aren't we haven't arrived
no so we have to get up and persist
right but
we got these big visions i want the
payoff and i got to be patient
so i got to get up and do i got to get
up and show up right
but i also got to wait yeah right some
of you spiritually waiting on the lord
in your prayer life
waiting to see that kid figure that out
you know it's all the things
i struggle so much there john i'm just
going to give you a second to
talk to me because i feel it with it
listen it could be for something you
desire or it could be something that you
need desperately
it again we it's our it's the air and
water that we
swim in and breathe and drink it's so
hard it's our culture that says
you know what you deserve it right you
deserve it now yeah and so they try to
remove the tension
i'm gonna pull all attention away i'm
gonna make it to where you don't have to
think about buying it i'm just gonna
just give me your number i'll do it
automatically i'm just gonna send it to
your house
you don't need to think about it that's
right why would what kind of loser
thinks about their electric bill
i got it just give us give me the number
i'll i'll charge you whatever i think's
a fair rate yeah right and if you go
back generations before it was
i'm going to buy things make decisions
based on its effect
seven generations from now what's it
right folks
slow down and this is the time of the
kettle here man
oh yeah we're preaching ourselves hey
look if you want something that really
matters
you're gonna have to embrace the tension
between persistence
and patience hey i got something that
will relieve your attention
there's more of the ramsay show coming
up don't move
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
the ramsay show rolls on from our ramsey
solutions
headquarters in nashville so excited to
have you with us eight
triple eight excuse me eight two five
five two two five john
you and i both do shows i almost
instinctively went into the number
for the ken coleman show yeah james the
producer over there that's happened i
think the many times i've posted i've
done it i linked i think twice
i think you need to do it like i do it
which is i don't have the other number
memorized yet
oh it's just on the floor i know see the
more you do it it's just like
sometimes incompetence comes in handy it
does
see thank you james that's really the
story played
well played but it really is a
psychological thing like you know it's
just amazing like how many times you say
that number and i
finally caught myself that's the first
time now that i've stopped it's like hey
oh there it is it's triple eight eight
two five five five
five two two five that's the number to
jump in triple eight eight two five
five two two five underestimate
incompetence yeah ever
it's true james bringing the heat he
does he beats me up all day long love
you john he has a low self-esteem i
let it happen it's part of my it's a
gift that's a thing
that's so good all right hey we're here
for your calls
and we're excited to do it baltimore
maryland is where we go
and oh actually okay there it is faith
in washington d.c that's where we're
going
to have a faith how can we help hi guys
um thank you so much for taking my call
i am calling the key
i delivered my dream job and parasites
hey faith um uh can you try to stand
still and hold that phone as close your
mouth as possible we're having a hard
time hearing you
sure there she is i got offered my dream
job and i am terrified
what are you terrified of so
i'm coming from the nonprofit sector
and switching into finance and i've been
passionately
interested in finance since i was 16 but
have never
done professionally and so i'm just
worried that i won't pass my exams that
you know i'll you know study for
everything and then just ultimately just
fail
tell us about the last time you worked
really hard on something and you just
failed it miserably
oh boy um college did you fail out of
college
no i did not no i think at your
non-profit did you feel out of that
have you just been i did you failed out
of it
yeah i it was a long story but basically
i got fired from my last job and then
applied for my dream job kind of on the
floor
like well i got fired so i don't really
have anything to lose
then i got it but did you get fired for
incompetence
i got fired for a mistake that i made
that was kind of dumb but not like
grossly terrible there you go so that's
what's shaking you here's the deal
faith you just got the job they already
gave you the job
so you're in and so now you're going to
work on getting trained and you have
always wanted to do this
your equal parts excited and equal parts
oh
i've got this doubt because it's new and
i know what that feels like
it was 2017 faith i had just become a
ramsey personality
and i was in orlando florida with my
family and i got a call from jeremy
brelin who leads our personalities
and he said are you sitting down and i
said uh give me a second i sat down
on a park bench at a theme park
he said hey this is not a guarantee this
is gonna happen
but it looks like that siriusxm is gonna
do
a channel a ramsey network channel
and you're going to have a live show
leading into dave ramsey
monday through friday if this goes
through how does that feel
now faith i was instantly excited
and he peed his pants okay there you go
i was thinking more sick to my stomach
because then i was like wait a second
yes i'm excited i want to do this i've
always wanted to do it
but i hadn't done it on that level
before and faith
the day before i was as sick as i've
ever been in my life
about a job why because i'm where you
are right now i'd always wanted to do it
i built it up in my mind it was the
dream job it is the dream job by the way
but i hadn't done it and i was like what
if dave thinks my show
sucks what if i can't help anybody
they're gonna fire me my kids are going
to starve we're going to be living in a
box under the bridge
and my mind went bananas
faith what's the worst possible thing
that would happen
if you fail that first exam something i
don't think you're going to do
tell us um i'll get an additional 30
days to try again
oh okay so faith are you going to fail
miserably in this dream job
i i don't know i think it's not no
bad answer you get to take the retest
right now your name is faith
yes own your name have some
gee whiz the answer to that question is
no don't self-sabotage yourself yeah
you're going to crush this and like
if you don't then you get 30 more days
and you're going to do it again
i mean yeah i think it's also just like
i'm putting a lot of pressure on myself
because
my grandfather taught me everything that
i know about finance he passed away
a couple of years ago and so i'm also
you're not you're such a sweet sweet
sweet heart but i'm going to tell you
something your grandfather
you didn't disappoint him when he was
alive you're certainly not going to
dishonor him now
faith this is all you're just creating
all these reasons why
you may have stepped into the wrong
thing that's what you're trying to do
right now
because you're there and now you got to
take the test and so the fear of failure
while that
that fear is it's it's embodying in you
and it's very real
the reasons why you're fearful they
aren't legitimate we just walk through
them we put them on the witness stand
there's no evidence faith and we're
having some fun with you
but at the same time trying to shake you
out of this because you have created all
these
things that could happen if you simply
don't pass
a financial test i take that
fear and anxiety and i would channel
that towards studying my head off
and here's another cool thing faith
coming from the um
the non-profit world into the profit
world it's gonna be an adjustment here
so
i'll cut through the tape for you the
the for-profit world
hires people for one reason to make them
money
they would not have hired you if they
didn't think you could make them money
don't let your employer have more faith
in you than you do
okay they think you're worthy of the
challenge they think that you're gonna
make them money
that means you should believe them okay
you're gonna do a great job
and let me just again the reason i told
you and our listeners that story
is because i got to a point where i was
really nervous john before that first
day
i promise you more than i've ever been
nervous
and i got to the point where i said why
am i doing this and i started focusing
on where i wanted to go
why i wanted to do the show why i was
willing to suck yeah because you do when
you start oh the first time is the worst
time
and i said i'm going to focus on why i'm
doing this and this is the pain
right the root word of passion means to
suffer
i'm willing to suffer my own criticism
and suffer
through making those early mistakes and
not doing as good a job as i could have
done
to get to the opportunity to do it long
term and help as many people as possible
you must begin with the end in mind and
you can't be focusing on all the things
that could go wrong because guess what
some of them are going to go wrong but
most of them that you're terrified of
aren't going to actually materialize so
let's go to that all the way to the end
here
she goes and tanks her exams okay and
i'm not just talking about faith talking
anybody
they have this dream i used to deal with
this with my students
i was put on earth to do one thing be a
singer
the cosmos has called me to be a singer
i'm here and then they sing and you're
like
nope it didn't yeah it didn't right it
for sure yeah
isn't that right you know what still
true
person's still a person of value sure
still got purpose and passion
there is going to be some extraordinary
things they can do whether locally or
small or on a big scale
doesn't matter your who faith is is not
wrapped up and whether she becomes a
finance person or not and we often take
our identity and our future and our this
and it's all gonna come crashing down my
kids are gonna be able to eat
and they put a pressure on this one to
take the test yeah take the test
hit the dude in the mouth you're already
in the ring swing hard swing hard train
for the fight you're already in it yeah
i can just tell you
somebody who got hired for that job
already has the profession the
proficiency
that's right the talent to actually do
it so if you're not a good test taker
there's aids and all kinds of
opportunities and people that will tutor
you
there's so much help yes just ask for
help it's a choice and a decision
and study like your life depends on it
you'll pass the test who cares if it's
an a plus
call us back when you get to when you
when you pass the test oh that'll be fun
yeah we'll cheer for you yeah all right
folks we're just getting started
what do you need to talk about dr john
and not dr
kim are on the desk this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show we're
coming to you from our
national studios at our ramsey solutions
world headquarters i am ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john delony
and we are taking your calls triple
eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five
two two five let's go to baltimore
maryland where chase joins us on the
line chase how can we help
hi uh so i'm in high school i'm 16 years
old
i've played for mount st joseph high
school and we're a national team
in football and i play wide receiver and
i have a very good chance to go
to division one level and have a full
ride scholarship to college
but i just started a real estate
business and i make about
anywhere between five to 20k a month
whoa doing
real estate and my father did a business
and he scaled it up to a million dollar
business a year
and i know i can do that but i don't i
don't have the time and effort because i
only work about two days a week
so i want to see where you guys
depending on this whole situation should
be
my opinion is based on your answers
young man
congratulations first of all on what
you've been able to do
hold on so you're working about eight
days a month and you're making twenty
thousand dollars five to twenty thousand
yeah i work um mondays and one day two
days i don't go to school
and i work maybe three hours a day yeah
okay so chase
do you want to play division one
football
yeah since i was young and what's the
dream beyond that do you have a dream
for the nfl
yeah i've been for nfl and i have a
dream for usa as well so yeah but here's
the deal
here's the deal you don't have to choose
between the two what if i told you you
could
you could pursue both dreams
that would be that would be the best
part okay now here's the catch
you cannot pursue both dreams
at the same pace that's the catch
do you understand what i mean by that
yeah
sure you do so here's the deal you're
already
way ahead of so many young people i mean
you're in the top like point two percent
of young people in the country as far as
just
making income while being in high school
you can continue to grow that business
your dad's got great expertise as you
have laid out
you can hire some really good people to
continue to grow that but if your dream
is to play division one football
you need to go for that and if you want
to take a shot
if your health stays and you got the
prospects and you get to the point where
you're
you're an actual uh prospect
go for it because if the nfl doesn't
come calling
you've got not a fallback plan you've
got another dream
waiting on you so i i say you pursue
both but understand you're going to have
to be patient on the real estate thing
because you cannot grow it to the level
you want to grow it to until
you can go full time at it but both of
those dreams are
there you're running at both of those
just different paces john
yeah man if you have the opportunity to
go go play football man
i look at it as can't tell me if i'm
wrong here i look at it as
as a scale if you will you can't
get to be 27 and say man i'm really done
with this
real estate dream it's time for me to go
to college and play football
that does not happen very well you can't
flip it that way yeah you can
get through your sophomore year of
college and realize i don't like the
pressure of d1 football it's a lot
that's
a full-time job it's a life i don't like
it i'm going to roll out of here go sell
houses
you can do that right so absolutely one
of those things you
have to do now or you're cashing it out
the other will continue to be with you
as long as you go
and so man i i say double down and
here's the thing
enjoy your life you're 16 man yeah
you're 16.
real estate's not going anywhere yeah
and chase here's the other thing
i think you trying to grow this thing
while being a full-time student athlete
i think it's going to make you a better
business person for the day when you
actually
retire from sports whether that's in
college if an injury happens which could
happen
or you go it's not for me and i'm tired
of the two a days and you know all the
stuff i i think if you grow this thing
as a part-timer to the point that you
already have it if you can keep doing it
it's gonna make you better because you
figured out how to grow it
on a scaled part-time basis and you
you want to talk about repeatable
principles that you're going to be able
to do
man i think you're in great shape so go
play football yeah and enjoy enjoy high
school go play football yeah see what
happens
absolutely triple eight eight two five
five two two
five is the number to jump in on the
conversation
dr john deloney is my colleague with me
this hour i'm ken coleman
justin's up next in chattanooga
tennessee justin how can we help
uh yeah so i was actually just hoping to
get some kind of career advice
all right what's the question so uh
well right now i'm just a general
laborer basically
uh i mean i work in a factory but i want
to get into the tech industry in some
way form or fashion
you know to make more money and to be
more fulfilled
and so i was just wondering if you had
any advice about how to go about doing
that
because i don't know if i should go to
school because i'm 28
or if i should do something online or
how to do that okay so what we first
start with justin is
what is the type of tech work we want to
do we don't have to be exactly sure but
we want a ballpark idea
do you have a couple of ideas or one
clear winner in your mind when you think
of this is the tech job that i would
like to get into
well i do want to get into development
so like making
web uh websites phone apps video games
that stuff
okay so here's what you do so you're
clear so now we want to focus on what's
it take to get qualified and the general
assumption
which i know that you've got an open
mind uh is that well i got to go to
four-year school
no you do not not to be a developer
and so what you've got to do is you got
to go a little deeper than my
general knowledge but to be a developer
there are uh
certain skills and then there are
certain certifications and things like
that that you need are you aware of that
i am i'm just not sure i mean there's so
many out there i'm not sure which ones
would be
good ones to get and then they all
they're all expensive so i just don't
know which ones to focus on
okay so what you need to do is i love
this and what you want to do is just
start to talk to developers
in chattanooga chattanooga tennessee do
you know anybody who's actually a
developer
i do not and i've been trying to find
someone to talk to i just also don't
know how to go about actually finding
those people well i'm telling you
so what you need to do is you personally
have just said i don't know anybody
that's a developer so what you need to
do is
you think of all of your friends and
family in the chattanooga area
then you start thinking of all the
acquaintances you have including
co-workers
and you talk to everybody you come in
contact with
you know what maybe the butcher that you
get your meat from hey
you know anybody that's a developer
because this is what the process is
right you don't start with the butcher
john but i was making the point
you're gonna get to the book you're
gonna find a developer and then you say
hey
would you make a connection for us and
just say look uh
my god justin here he just wants to pick
your brain
uh wants to be a developer and wants to
get your insight knowledge most people
are gonna be willing to do that because
they feel
valuable by doing that and so that's the
beginning of what i wrote in the book
the proximity principle which says in
order to do what justin wants to do
he's got to be around people that are
doing it developers he's got to be in
places where development is happening so
even if you know somebody
justin who works in a company that
employs developers
call that person they're your good
friend and they and then say hey
would you ask them if i could shadow
them for a day now justin do you know
anybody
that works in a company that has
employees that are developers
uh not to my knowledge the answer is yes
you do
yes you do you just haven't started this
process so don't make this so difficult
literally you're talking to everybody
that that you know now here's one other
thing i want you to do
i want you to go to betheltech.net they
are a partner of the ken coleman show
they are training people in a nine month
period
online you don't have to go anywhere you
can do it at home
and ramsay solutions listeners they get
a discount because they're paying cash
you can cash flow your way through this
they have a nine month program it's less
than fifteen thousand dollars and they
can get you qualified they place you
uh making seventy five thousand dollars
just getting started within a couple of
years as developer you're gonna make six
figures that's just one option i'm not
telling you they're the only option
but there are other organizations like
that go do your homework
all you got to do is search and those
type of options like bethel tech it's
betheltech.net
ken if you want to just talk to them do
your homework talk to them are they the
right fit or is there another
school like that that will do this all
online
pay as you go and they're going to get
you equipped they can tell you what you
need as well so talk to real developers
get their take get three or four of them
those opinions like in a bucket
talk to betheltech talk to other
organizations locally there's probably
some in tennessee
john just do your homework ask lots of
questions
and just like we tell people for our
smart investor pros
go with the one that feels right the
best fit and
justin you can get there and you will
start today all right great hour john
always fun and also with you thank you
sir to our producer james childs
our associate producer and call scanner
kelly dean thank you all very much but
mostly thank you folks
for listening this is the ramsey
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloni
we are ramsey personalities and we host
shows of our very same name and we are
here
together to serve you this hour triple
eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number
triple eight
eight two five five two two five john
tell them what calls you specialize in
tell them now what is it you gotta have
your mic out of there
it is relationships mental health all of
it there it is
education what's going on in your hearts
and your minds and your families and
your workplace and your
communities all of it all right and then
i specialize in
hey what were you born to do is work
just a job
that's designed to give you what money
you need to live or
are you created to contribute in your
work is there a purpose i think you were
created to fill a unique role in your
work that means you are needed
and it means you must do it somebody
needs you to show up so how do you make
the transition how do you discover what
that work is or if you know what it is
you don't know how to get there how do
you get there or
uh oh what if you're on the path john
and you're not getting promoted as fast
as you like so
those are the type of things we talk
about and of course we're gonna talk
about your money
so there you go open phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number dallas texas is where we go next
chase joins us there chase how can we
help
hey so i just got a new job
um i'm getting paid double what i'm
going to be
uh what i was getting paid hey
congratulations
that's awesome so um it comes with a
relocation
after some math um my emergency fund
looks a bit excessive
um it's i'm moving into a lower overall
cost of living area significantly lower
and my six months of expenses that i've
got saved up now is looking more like
10.
if i move to um wow to where i'm moving
so
do i just save that as a instead of
rainy day fund a
nuclear fallout fund do i move that
around
i won't be eligible to uh put into a
401k
until uh 90 days into my employment so i
haven't
quite reached that yet um and my roth is
already maxed
my roth ira is already maxed out for the
year are you gonna buy a house
are you gonna rent uh right now we're
renting
okay do you have any intention because
that's my first thought is roll that
into a
down payment fund for a house yeah right
yes we aren't really looking for sure to
um
to settle down into a house yet because
i'm
my goal is actually to relocate uh with
this company after
putting in a few years and but but but
still you're not maybe
at that point right right you know
start putting that into separate savings
or what do you well i'm with john on
this i mean there's
there i think there's two ways to go i
think i'm with john that
because you guys are a young couple and
you're making some great progress you're
in wonderful financial shape
i'd put that in in a nice you know my
market account nice money market account
and sit on it until you guys get clear
with what you want to do the other
option is
you certainly could invest that uh with
our gross stock mutual fund strategy and
things like that and
let that money start working for you but
again let's say that two years from now
you keep moving up the ladder
and you move and now you're ready to buy
and that money we'd never tell you to
pull that out now that you've invested
that money and it's doing good for you
but
it's prolonging that down payment on a
home i like parking
it in the uh uh in in the fun and where
you where you can make a little bit so
you know you're not gonna get a huge
return on it right now but um
it gives you options i just wouldn't let
it burn a hole in your pocket
right all right thank you yes okay
that's good
yeah i think we're good there i think
he's only got a couple options there you
know i hate to see him not
have that money available when he's
ready to buy a house yeah
ken why is it so hard to stay on a plane
you know what i mean
uh yeah that's a that's a deep question
i it's just it's
like you follow it you follow it you
follow it you know what i should be
doing to something else
well i'll tell you what i think is going
on with him okay he's going
i should be making progress with this
money ah okay
i don't need it for my it's too much for
my emergency fund
is it really i mean because here's what
i hate about my emergency fund
using it oh man yeah you know that's
true
absolutely as soon as you have to dip
into it i never feel
i i am grateful for it but i always go
oh
geez i want to get dead i got to fill
that back up so is it really that bad to
have a
couple of extra months or four months in
his case no but i think it's the mindset
of progress
we humans we're like well i got this
extra money if i just put it savings
i'm just wasting it setting it on fire
yeah right instead of working towards
something
i think that's it don't you i mean
that's the only thing i could think of
other than
i i just know i can get two months into
a really great workout program
see some really great progress and i
start getting bored
yeah and then i think you know what i
probably should be doing something else
and then i look up two months later
i'm completely derailed doing something
nonsensical in there yeah i think this
guy's on top of things and he's just
falling into the progress trap
that's a good question and it's a good
playful question yeah yeah
triple eight eight two five five two two
five norfolk virginia is where we go now
adriana is on the line how can we help
hi it's honored to talk to you all so my
question is
that i've been i'm in college that i've
managed to save a thousand dollars and
i'm wondering
would it be better for me to put that
money into an s p 500 growth eps in my
roth ira
or into my business how much money did
you say
a thousand dollars a thousand what's
your side business
so my side of business is called the
parental craze it's the body care
business where i just make
products like lotions and organic
natural products like that
and it brings in about 50 to 60 a week
so like 3 000 a year and i just want to
keep growing my business
okay so yeah i i wouldn't put a thousand
dollars in the stock market i would just
open
a business account a checking savings
account and leave it there yeah
give yourself that cushion in that side
business you don't want to lock it up in
the stock market with just a thousand
dollars that's going to be what you
reinvest in your company that's going to
be your emergency fund for your company
that's going to be your scaling money
for your company so that's us that's
you're you're well in your way you're
planting seeds for a future company
there but yeah i wouldn't
overthink that money yeah absolutely
thank you for the call
uh let's see thomas is up in salt lake
city utah thomas how can we help
yeah so i'm just trying to get back into
financial stability i was out of work
for a while due to
a medical issue and suffered depression
and
just totally ruined uh overdue banking
counts
and they've got loans and just trying to
see like
there's life at the end of the tunnel
yeah well there absolutely is
give us a snapshot of what your
financial situation
is um right now i probably owe
around uh i took like two loans at work
probably like
2800 i owe
i have a car payment and my rent's
really
next to nothing cause i live with a good
friend how much do you owe on your car
um just over
eight thousand so you have you have
twenty eight hundred dollars in
loans you have eight thousand dollar in
a car what other debt
uh student loans how much
um probably eighteen okay all right
thomas here's what we're gonna do
that music means we're coming up on a
network break but good news for you
i got you on hold when we come back
we're going to get the full picture
of what your debt situation is we've got
the plan the baby steps work for you
we'll walk you through that we're going
to help you out don't go anywhere
john's going to talk to you a little bit
about some of that emotional stuff that
you might be carrying
as well thank you thomas for the call
thank you for your patience folks don't
move we're going to help thomas and you
on the other side of the break this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from nashville
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney
as we went into our last break thomas
had joined us
and thomas has been through some stuff
john we haven't heard the whole story
yet we're gonna get to it but as a
result of some of the stuff he's been
through
he's in a tough financial spot so we're
getting a sense of where he
is and so we bring thomas back on here
so we can dive in all right thomas
uh so i want to make sure i have the
full debt picture
2 800 in some loans 8 000
uh on the car and 18 000 in student loan
debt
is there any other debt that you have
um let's just put it up to like with the
loans probably like
34 just in case okay 34
everything included yeah okay and then
other debts um not that i could think of
the top of my head right now now
so i'm a little nervous about the fact
that off the top of your head you can't
think of any other debt that you might
have so um i we want to know
that this is your financial picture and
then are you in a uh
are you an employee are you employed
right now or are you in between jobs
what's going on there
employed a full-time job plus i just
took a little
part-time every other week like 12 hours
being a doorman for a bar
how much are you making in the full-time
job
um just over
22. okay and how much you're bringing in
on the part-time job
11 an hour or 12 so let's say 12 hours
every two weeks
okay all right john you were going to
jump in
yeah so i want to back up a little bit
man why did you
what was the medical issue are you in
hospital uh
blood clots in my leg and then i was out
of work for about
i don't know two months and yeah got
really depressed
okay and so you had some medical issues
that pulled you out of work
tell me about this depression um
i'm not really one that he's sitting
around all the time okay and i was
sitting in my house
and i couldn't work and i'm blood class
and i was also
because of the depression uh decided
that drinking would solve the depression
which made it worse
and what what what kind of rattled your
cage a little bit to get you
back out of the house and get a job did
you get a clean bill of health
yeah i uh my doctor finally allowed me
to go back to work and
then um i was drinking a lot and
overdrew bank accounts from my bank
account and decided just need to stop so
yeah do you have an alcohol problem uh
i don't think so i just think i was
self-medicating when i knew i shouldn't
have been
is being a doorman at a bar the smartest
position for you right now
um i don't know to be honest i haven't
thought about that
yeah it's probably not okay
what is it about you that thinks you're
worth 22 000
a year
um i will really i just was trying to
get out of this financial situation so
i was ready to take anything to help
bring in a little bit extra money
what do you want to do thomas what have
you dreamed about
man i want to travel um i'm on like my
my
my bucket list main bucket list is to
see every uh major league
game and every part of heart all right i
appreciate that dream what are you
dreamed about
doing what kind of work do you think
about you know if i'm doing this kind of
work
and i'm making this kind of contribution
through my work i'm a happy man
it's my perm well it's my full-time job
is is i i work for a great company and i
don't see myself ever living in this
place
what are you doing i still don't know
what you do um
oh i'm a cable um technician okay and so
you love working with your hands and
solving problems with your head and
hands
yes okay so if you want to stay with
that company do you see a ladder
at that company where you keep moving up
have you looked ahead definitely
okay good and they're going to pay more
than 22 000 a year
yes okay so i'm going to jump on
something that john said he's right you
need to get you need to quit the bar
job today you don't need to be hanging
out in a bar when you've just come
through some really tough
battles with alcohol what you need to do
is get a side job fixing stuff
because that's what you're good at you
use your head and your hands to solve
problems
and in this economy in the trades you
can make some really good side money and
i i love that you said you've identified
this company as a ladder for you
so that's great but you need to get out
of that unhealthy environment that's
just not a good place for you make some
more money
uh so that you can get out of debt and
you need to get gazelle intense are you
single
uh or you got a relationship what's
going on there
bengal how old are you 38
38 okay so you're only making 22
000. you need to be you need to be
working yourself well
hold on hold on when you asked how much
i made i was pointing i was talking to
you about 22 an hour
um yeah oh okay okay okay i went with
jono so what are you making
oh i apologize yes yes 22 just over 22
an hour i apologize like 48 a year
okay oh okay that helps me sleep a
little better all right so here's how we
get financially
here's how you get financially stable
you're gonna walk the baby steps out
have you heard us talk about the baby
steps
i have i need to get the book to really
realize what they are
we're going to give it to you all right
i'm going to send it to you for free
we're going to send you the book for
free
total money makeover we're also going to
give you a free trial to ramsey plus
which will come with uh there are
budgeting world-class budgeting app
every dollar so that you're not going uh
uh like you have been on most of the
questions you actually know where your
money is and you learn how to budget
there's some other great tools in there
as well okay so we're gonna give you
ramsey plus
a free trial we're gonna give you the
book total money makeover but here's
what you do
baby step one is you need to put a
thousand dollars in a
savings account and that is your first
emergency fund
a thousand dollars baby step two is we
begin to attack
your debt and we call it the debt
snowball and that is the smallest debt
you attack that first if you've got a
minimum payment
of a couple hundred bucks on one of
those loans or whatever you're attacking
everything you've got extra beans and
rice
you are working another job that's not
in a bar making as much money as
possible and you are attacking
that smallest debt once you eliminate
that smallest debt
you take the minimum payment that you
were putting into that plus everything
else you were throwing at it
and you roll it into the next thing are
you tracking with me thomas
yes yes you can have this 34 000 paid
off
for 18 months how much is your car worth
oh um 3 000. all right so you don't have
much there so you gotta knock down so
here's the deal
you are working hard you're working so
hard you don't have time to take a drink
yeah you're getting off of work and
you're
you're going straight into delivering
for uber or whatever uber eats and
you're hitting the road until late at
night and you're getting up and you're
doing it again to get this debt paid off
okay
okay but yeah listen i'm just saying
this thomas please go get a trade job
you can fix stuff with your hands you
know enough guys in the business you're
in that's where you'll make the most
hourly money
go do something you're really good at
and keep getting a skill while you're
doing it do you understand what i'm
saying don't work in a bar
yes get good while you're getting out of
debt
and here's the beautiful thing about
healing from depression it's little
winds
and little winds and little winds little
steps and little steps
okay and you said it best
we're not made to sit at home and it's
frustrating and it was it was exhausting
for you
and the thing that sucks about alcohol
is it helps it works for a season
and then it kills you right it takes
everything from you and you experience
that firsthand
so i want you to look at going back to
work
hard getting that second job ken was
talking about getting a third job on the
weekends after that
i want you to look at those little
little steps little steps you're going
to look up in 18 months i want this
thirty four thousand dollars gone
i want it gone so hang on the line here
we're gonna give you a copy of total
money makeover we're gonna get you
signed up for ramsey plus
and we want you to follow this through
and i want you to call us back in a year
when this debt's almost gone or 18
months when it's totally gone
and we're gonna cheer with you yeah
little steps little steps you can do
this brother
we got faith in you thomas listen to me
thank you
listen to me what has happened to you
and what you did
is not who you are it does not define
you
use this as a refiner's fire and you've
been in the fire and then like the
blacksmith puts that
wrought iron into the fire and lets it
get crazy hot then he pulls it out
what's he doing then beat him
and he shapes it let this thomas shape
you
and your best days are ahead young man
don't you get down
i understand why you did but believe
that you've got a unique contribution to
make and i think you've seen the latter
and that's exciting get focused get your
eyes on the prize and do not quit
there is light at the end of every
tunnel that's true good stuff all right
i'm looking to my left out in the lobby
of ramsey solutions and i see a very
excited young couple
and they're gonna do a debt-free scream
it's our favorite part of the show and
it's coming up next don't move this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delony
it is a free call to jump in on the
conversation triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight two five five two two five and in
the lobby of ramsey solutions
oh it's a fantastic young couple
standing on the stage christian
and lauren are with us christian lauren
hello
hey hi guys how you guys feeling right
now pretty good
[Laughter]
where are you from we're from i'm
originally from oklahoma but uh we live
in austin texas right now austin texas
all right okay so how much debt have you
paid off
we paid off 62 000 in 18 months whoa wow
all right and uh what was the range of
income we started at a 114 000 and ended
up with about 150 by the end
whoa tell me about that rise in income
well it's it's working a lot of nights
uh staying up late
arguing with each other late at night
while we're working um but a lot of a
lot of side work what do you guys do for
a living
uh i work in product marketing at a tech
company and
and then i also do social media
marketing at a tech company as well okay
same company or different companies
different different yeah yep what was
the late night arguing about i mean
i think social media probably probably
social media
yeah not going to bed together that's
always annoying yeah we took on some
side projects so i think it was just
hard sometimes
working the late nights having different
nights we work late
and we started paying off debt right as
we got married
um about two years ago so it was jumping
straight into it
see how we're figuring out how to be
married anyway much less absolutely
working like crazy
yeah wow so what was the debt
it was uh about a 50 50 split um about
29 000
in a truck that i decided that we needed
as soon as we graduated and got married
of course
and then about 30 low 30s in uh student
loans
okay all right oh boy and so what was
the what was the impetus to do this here
you are this young couple and what
what was it and when did it happen well
it took a little while i think it took
us about six months to get on the same
page
i grew up super uh i was i took a lot of
debt out i
took a student or a loan on a car when i
was 16.
super used to that she had never had
that before um we knew we wanted to
change our family tree
so we got on the same page and just uh
went after it
how'd you come in contact with ramsay
solutions in this this financial piece
and baby steps how'd that come to you
the podcast listen to the podcast we had
a bunch of eight hour road trips up to
oklahoma and i uh
subjected lauren to a lot of pain on
those drives
how painful was it well i think for me
it was a little bit harder to get on
board just because
i've never i think coming to the idea of
us having to pay off this massive amount
of debt so early in our marriage
i was a little bit angry about that and
so i remember he would play these
podcasts and be like
turn them off and then i remember one
trip i finally was like
okay we're gonna do this and then six
months into our marriage we started
really
committing to the plan and like actually
moving forward with it together
who told who the trucks got to be sold
we didn't sell it
oh yeah yeah we did tell each other many
times and we should sell it
um but we did decide to keep it yeah
they kept it
wow so what do you tell young couples or
anybody quite frankly who's
early on in this journey they've decided
they're going to do it
but they're mad like you were lauren i
don't want to do this don't make me do
it
what do you say to him i would say
commit to it
it's so so worth it early on in your
marriage
and it really does help you become a
team together which is so important in
marriage and
even though a lot of people would be
angry about it being so early
in marriage it really right off the bat
just starts you on a good foot so when
you
when you see you keep mentioning early
in marriage yeah are you talking about
this idea that
when you're newly wed everything should
just be roses and
beach fronts and like swimming in lake
travis just running around being like
instead of working all day and then
working all night and saturday and
sunday
yeah i think there's this whole idea
that your first few years of marriage
need to be this
beautiful bliss and so easy and i think
that was the hardest part for us was
a bunch of our friends who got newly
married were buying houses
and they were really like starting this
beautiful life well we were in a 700
still are in a 700 square foot apartment
together
both working from home and so i think
the comparison was really hard in the
beginning for us and now you understand
that that lifestyle
that your friends are getting married is
a mirage yeah it's a charade
right yes and you're gonna walk out of
this 700 square foot
apartment with this strapping young man
next to you with the filson hat
and y'all gonna go walk straight into a
debt-free
next rest of your life right so this
stuff that when you finally achieve
those things
it's gonna be real it's gonna build be
built on a strong relational foundation
financial foundation
and it's got long-term life-changing
stuff right yeah absolutely yeah
now we know you guys by this rise in
income and you've already told us you
guys worked like crazy
which is great what are some of the
sacrifices or what's one of the wackiest
thing to your friends or family maybe
that you guys did to either cut expenses
or pay something off faster
well no i would say one for us lauren
loves to travel
absolutely no vacations we went to
puerto rico for our honeymoon and this
is our first vacation
in about two years yeah so this is very
similar to puerto rico
yeah well played yeah that's awesome uh
so
was there a point in this journey um
in the 18 months where it clicked where
we went from
struggle and just striving to oh
this is we feel some momentum here i'm
just curious
yeah i think for me it was about three
months in lauren
and i finally got on the same page and
we went from paying that 500
a month car payment to getting after it
putting thousands and thousands a month
towards debt
and we just got pretty pissed off to be
honest and
that's when it clicked and we decided if
we're gonna do it let's do it and let's
do it quick
what did it feel like to get that truck
title in the mail amazing
yeah it's all mine there's millions of
people who have never felt that and
there's something about getting that
truck title that's just like
ah it's mine right right and it's also
awesome when she's not mad at you
anymore for making such a terrible yeah
isn't that true yeah you touched on this
earlier i just want to ask this really
quick i want you to speak to couples
you can both jump in on this if you want
uh yes you're a young married couple but
you're just a married couple forget the
amount of time
when you jumped on together on this
journey and you really locked arms and
got going together and now you're on the
other side of this about ready to do
your screen what is it done for your
marriage and your relationship
i think personally on my end it's just
taken so much pressure
off of each other and
we both have a lot of dreams that we
want to pursue in the future and so
i think it just allows us that extra
freedom to be able to go do that
i think for me the the biggest part of
the journey in our marriage was just the
unity that it brought
between us just to have to work together
towards a common goal
um it was just awesome struggle
ends up in connection man that's so
great i'm excited for you all
congratulations for setting a model for
couples who've been married for 50 years
or couples who've been married for two
months
couples who are thinking about it good
for you guys you're on the stage now
the finish line is right before you guys
ready to do this let's do it
all right here we go folks it is
christian and lauren from austin texas
they paid off 62 000.18 months going
from 114k to 152k
count it down let's hear your debt free
screen
three two one we're debt-free
there it is they did it
look at that look at that gaze isn't
that fun
the married couple the young married
couple they haven't been on a vacation
since the honeymoon but worse they went
to oklahoma a few times
that's the opposite of a vacation oh man
the texas boy taking a shot
across the red river there uh kelly
daniel at texan uh
is very excited she's got like touchdown
hands in the control room
yeah hey they put the time in and here's
what they didn't know they were doing
they knew they were getting out of debt
but they didn't know
they were investing in this struggle and
struggle when you struggle together
it works with our military it works with
sports teams it works with
with businesses working relationships
when you struggle together for a common
purpose
man it builds connection it builds a
strength it makes that
that connect connective tissue so strong
so tight
good for them i'm so excited for them
yeah it's really true coming out on the
other side of the storm
i it just makes that sun warmer
brighter i wish i could see how big
they're smiling oh
literally they're lighting up the studio
in here for you podcast listeners yeah
it's
awesome why by the way you need to check
it out on youtube my goodness gracious
stakes alive to watch that it's uh it's
invigorating so
[Music]
we gotta go say hi and congratulate and
high-five him but don't move
more of the ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
nashville
ramsay solutions studio so excited to
have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloni
and we are taking your questions about
life
relationships work money just general
progress
we want to equip you and encourage you
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
are you tired of feeling stuck with your
money like you're never gonna get out of
debt or save enough for the future
it doesn't have to be that way you can
make progress with your money and faster
than you think
but you've got to have a budget that's
why you need a ramsey plus
membership you're going to get access in
ramsey plus to the premium version of
our every dollar budgeting app where
you'll plan out every dollar you spend
and save
before the month begins you'll connect
your budget to your bank
so you never miss a transaction and
you're going to get custom budget
reports that show you
where you can find more money to put to
your towards your goals when you budget
and get intentional with your money
you will make progress and quickly you
can start budgeting for free today
start your free trial of ramsey plus by
texting the word
trial to 33789 that's trial
two three three seven eight nine hey ken
before we move on
um you've got a massive cool big event
coming up
can you tell us about it oh yeah thank
you very much uh it's coming up
tuesday april the 27th it's entitled
get hired and basically what we're doing
is a deep dive into how you beat the
competition you think about how
competitive the job market is now
and quite frankly even when you know you
have a lower unemployment rate
when you're when you're interviewing for
a job or you're trying to find the right
job it's
a process and so we're going to detail
the process out
what you need to be doing and then how
to do it it's called get hired
tuesday april the 27th live stream event
it's only 20
all you got to do is text the word hired
to 33789 text the word hired
to 33789 and uh like i said 20 bucks
john
could be a great gift for a college kid
who's trying to figure out how to
navigate this world or just somebody
who's down
feeling like hey i've i've applied i've
applied i've applied i've done
interviews i can't get hired
yes you can we're going to show you how
so thanks for bringing that up but yeah
it's going to be a fun live stream event
tuesday april 27th
8 eastern 7 central uh
get hired and i want to make sure
everybody knows over the last year
all these different companies have
thrown up all these different kinds of
live streaming events
which are basically glorified zoom
meetings
this is not our team is so world-class
dude they wish you and i have nothing to
do with as you know zero
right you've got a group of absolute
world-class
professionals back there and it will be
a production it'll be a show it'd be
worth sitting down and watching yeah
and um get some great clarity watch some
live things i'm excited for it man
we want to help you get ahead so check
it out all right to the phones
we go atlanta georgia is where we're
going to pick up bill
bill how can we help yes sir i
appreciate y'all taking my call
uh y'all doing all right gentlemen oh we
are really having a blast what's going
on
good uh forgive me i'm gonna be a little
bit nervous about this but oh you're
doing great
i am 62 years old i am a truck driver
uh i am on baby step number four
i'm thinking about going back to online
school
for i.t an i.t profession
uh it's just getting i i do enjoy my job
but it's just getting physically harder
on me every day and so i never plan
on actually retiring just maybe cutting
back on my hours
so i thought maybe getting into the i.t
field
would be something that would come up
maybe years from now
that i could get into where i could quit
driving a truck and start doing that
uh the community college in my area
offers some certificate programs at i.t
of different subjects and i was
wondering if
y'all thought that would be the best way
to go
well i think it's a really good way to
go i think you get to determine if it's
the best way to go
in the sense of is technology what you
really want to do in these later seasons
it certainly gives you that flexibility
and something that you can begin doing
pretty quickly
you know once you get that certification
and you can begin to to get
opportunities
to do it even while you're in the truck
you know some freelance type work i
think it gives you a lot of versatility
but what makes this is this the best
move
uh is this if this is what you really
want to do i will tell you that you
don't have to have a ton of technical
experience
to get technically qualified to be able
to do work like technology i mean i work
with a great organization that's
training people
in nine months so you know that's the
issue if this is something you really
want to do
yeah i think you should do it and i
think you should do it as cheaply as
possible you don't need a four-year
degree
that's not something you're entertaining
anyway so it's where who can train me
to do what i want to do so the question
is do you know what type of technology
work you want to do
no sir not yeah the different subjects
one of the first one i'm looking to is
just the i.t
fundamentals uh to get into the
uh beginning stages of it and then
probably progress
from there i don't think i'd ever be
good at being a programmer or something
like that but
actually a uh a help desk specialist
or somebody that works on computers or
something like that would be something
that i would
think i would really enjoy okay great so
bill here's where we start
so you're 63 you've got a lot of
relationships you know even more people
than you think you know
and so what you've got to do is you've
got this idea i think i'd like to do
some just
basic you know computer maintenance
fixes
it help you need to start to connect
with
over the phone over lunch or coffee
with somebody who's in that actual job
and the reason you do this
this is the equivalent of the old days
when you were in school
and you would do some type of a term
paper or some type of a report where you
would research something
and so we want to do is we want to
clarify and verify you've got an idea we
want to clarify everything that's
involved in that on a day-to-day basis
what are you doing what do these folks
like about it the most what do they like
the least
and then you want to look into all right
what's it going to take to get qualified
to get into that
and so that's the clarify and verify
when you look into all those answers
your heart's going to either go ding
ding ding
or the big red family feud x and so bill
that's all you've got to do
so that's what i want you to do i want
you to really start hanging out with
or try to talk to people that are doing
that type of i.t work
and it's going to verify it for you
okay that sounds good i appreciate that
hey bill i want to tell you
one more thing you have just
this is this this has been a a long day
here
we've been working since early this
morning i want you to know that
you have absolutely put some wind in my
sails and you have called
everyone in america's bluff who says
this is just what i do
i've been doing this too long to to fill
in the blank
um i know my back hurts my knees hurt
but i can't do any feeling
this is what i'm talking about bill of
somebody who's looking to the future and
saying
i'm never too young to go learn
something new i'm never too young to go
call my local community college class i
got the courage
to do something different to do
something hard to change my mind
to do both and bill i want to tell you
you're a hero without a cape on
and i'm grateful that you called here
you're gonna help people
so much get over that hump that i can't
it's too i'm too old it's too late
that's right
all that is bull crap you can you just
gotta decide
i'm gonna go suck it up and i'm gonna go
get a certificate i'm gonna go like ken
said i'm gonna go sit down and talk to
somebody and bill i'd hug you if you
were here
i'm so grateful that you called man yeah
you're not too old it's not too late
the reason that people aren't sure if
they can john is because they don't know
how
right when we figure out the how and i
mean that when i say we've all done a
term paper
in high school or college but it's
different even the how though cause it's
it's bill's gotta it could easily be i
don't
i'm gonna feel uncomfortable sitting in
a class in a whole college class that's
like a 19 year old
that's true yep you are yeah yeah you're
right you have once you are confronted
with the how you still have to do it
gotta go do it there's no question about
it but i'm telling you one of the
biggest
obstacles for folks is they they
they have this idea that i'm too old i
can't do it it's gonna be too expensive
it's going to take too long
and they're filling in the answers
themselves they don't have the real
answers
and that's what we're imagining a bet
worst case scenario
or an embarrassment or a failure and
then they reverse engineered it right
now and they just stay put that's why i
love the clarify and verify
just go sit with somebody who's doing
that work yeah and
answer the questions that you don't have
answers to
and all of a sudden it's not so
difficult i mean that's why i wrote the
book the proximity principle that's how
i got into broadcasting starting at 33
with no degree and no connections
i got around the people that were doing
it and i got in places where the work
was happening
i kept showing up and doing it and then
opportunities presented themselves let's
not overthink this is the point folks
and have the courage and go do to yeah
just step out
it is going to be uncomfortable i
promise you all right hey john thanks as
always for hanging out love being with
you i want to thank our producer james
child
i want to i want to thank our associate
producer at call screen kelly daniel but
most of all
you america thank you for listening this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
this is the
the ramsay show the ramsay show it's the
ramsay show i almost said the dave
ramsey show for the first time it is the
ramsay show it's just the ramsey
thank you john we are broadcasting from
the dollar car riddle studio
and this is in fact the ramsey show it's
where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
and your money i'm ken coleman
who almost said it wrong and then just
owned it right on the air and
everybody's like why did you want to do
this because i had to stop the brain
it just happens when you go that's not
the way you're supposed to do it
and then you do it john delodie is with
me he bailed me out on that for
reminding me
what we actually call the show and
what's most important is
is that we can actually answer your
questions even just even with the uh
the the brain blips that happen from
time to time which is live broadcasting
it you know it's just kind of like what
what what what what
you got to say it the right way you know
if i've got a work or relationship or
money question
my confidence is brimming right now
it's so true these two guys here's the
last that helped me here's the lesson
here's the lesson when when you have
that
happen to you you go on you move on you
have to step right into it
stop call it out move on yeah yeah it's
not the end of the world
you know write that book yeah you know
the show business you know you keep
going you watch these american idol
shows and the kid forgets the lyrics
and it's in the moment it's it's like
death to them and it's like that happens
to everybody and
you just keep rolling regardless of it
but you gotta acknowledge it and then
move on
yeah absolutely triple eight eight two
five five two two five so we're gonna
take your questions on money
we'll take it on work we will take it on
relationships
and uh and between the two of us we're
gonna get an entire complete sentence
out that will answer
most if not all of your questions yeah
all the time yeah it's just every once
in a while you're gonna have that blip
hey david joins us now in traverse city
michigan david how can we help
yes i'm here david go ahead brother on
the line how can we help
my question is my wife and i we sold our
house and we have to build another one
and just wondering if we should see a
banker and get a loan
we're going to try to do it debt free
and we may be 40 to 50 000
short so you just said two conflicting
things
so you sold your house you have a pile
of cash here y'all just renting right
now
yes okay and so you're going to build
a dream home or a fancy home then the
traverse city is a beautiful beautiful
place you got a lot you're going to
build on
yes already had that that's already paid
for and we are
completely debt-free all right no car
payments no credit
cards my business is completely
debt-free also
excellent so you want to build this debt
free you're going to build this debt
free
but you're going to be 50 000 short and
you may need to get a mortgage
help me exactly possibly we'll be short
dependent on how long it takes us to
build it
walk me through that math well
for the first five years i built my
company up not taking anything
and now i can start reaping the rewards
from that
and the way house the way lumber prices
are and materials
we don't know what that's going to end
up being in six or seven months
when we're almost done with the house
so you think you're gonna have a fifty
thousand dollar overage just in material
cost alone
possibly yes okay but how you you're a
guy that's clearly analyzed this
i mean what are the chances of that
happening do you feel like that's a
greater than 50 percent chance
how are you how are you running those
numbers in that analysis to be able to
go
this could happen what are the variables
well it depends on if it takes us six
months or nine months if it takes us
nine months
i could see us not owing anything on it
but if it takes us six months
and my wife is pressuring me to go talk
to a banker
and i don't want to do it because i want
to completely debt free the way dave
ramsey wants you to do it
well what can you control doing it in
nine months
yes well i i feel like that's what we
need to be doing right
well yeah i i agree but i'm just saying
is it
wise for me should i think about
getting a loan or should i just say
forget it and just do it
here's the thing how much how much how
much you sell your other house for
uh we sold it for 324. so you have 324
thousand dollars in cash and in your in
your checking account
for all intents oh we have we have
no we have like 240 right now so you got
240 000
and so you're gonna build a 250 to 300
000
house right um no
like a 375 000 house because i've never
taken anything out of my company
and now i'm starting to take what i
should take out of the company
okay so let me just make this pretty
simple
if you're gonna put down 90
down on a house i got no problem with
you taking out a loan for that last
little bit
if you have worked like you have to
build up a business
and saved your money paid off your house
now you've sold your house
man what's three more months right
that's what i'm thinking yeah
why three more it sounds like this is a
much more of a marriage issue than it is
a math problem well it's it's
not really a marriage issue she just
wants me to
make sure that if we are short that we
can get
if we need to the extra 40 000 or 50 and
what we
what should we do should we um get a
helic loan or just get a personal loan
or finance the house if we if we have to
yeah yeah it's a marriage issue in that
what john's saying is your wife wants
you to do something that you don't want
to do and i think you told me you don't
think you have to do it
so don't do it if you're calling us to
say
we agree with your wife we don't
yeah i just i wouldn't i mean you can as
john said but you don't have to
here's here's the the big picture here
david is is um
either way you're gonna be okay yeah
either way you're gonna be fine you're
just gonna go get out a
a mortgage loan that's gonna be for that
gap
right you're gonna say hey we're gonna
put 90 down on this house or 95
down in this house we're gonna go get
the loan that's gonna cover that gap
my concern with going to get a 50 000
pot as a quote unquote just in case is
that's how extra bathrooms get added on
that's how extra shops get added on in
the back
and suddenly you end up buying bigger
better
well let's go we got 50 000 here let's
go ahead and the mortgage
payment's only going to be x and what
you end up going way over than what you
wanted to do
so i'd rather see you guys scale this
budget down get somebody to lock it in
there and go buy it or
just be okay saying we're gonna put 375
000
down on this house 325 000 we're gonna
we're gonna
finance the last 50 grand of it i don't
think that's the smart way but you're
not going to hurt anybody because you're
going to pay it off really quick then
you're going to be done with it
it sounds like you're overthinking it by
um
a hundred degrees and i get the
overthinking because of the psychology
of what you have gone through the pain
you've gone through to get debt free
and it's like why did we do all that
work just to turn right back around
and then take out a loan that's right
like 50 000 right so that's why that's
why ken and i are both telling you
man if it's you're talking three months
dude don't do it if you're like in three
months don't do it yeah
if you sold your house you put your
house in the market and you were hoping
it's going to sit for a year and it's
sold overnight
and now your wife is saying hey i don't
want to be renting for a year
you're not going to you're not going to
hurt anybody you're not going to ruin
anything by taking out three months
worth of
of a note yeah i just follow your heart
on this i mean i think it's very obvious
anybody listening that you know you
don't want to do that
and appreciate the call but i'd wait the
extra months but you know
that's what i would do i'd wait the
extra three months we'd have five you're
gonna feel much better about it and i
think that's what this whole call is
about is the feelings around
i've got these options here what do i do
so really appreciate the call and
congratulations on the sacrifice and
saving
to put yourself in that situation you
are in great shape
all right don't move more of your calls
coming around the corner this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney we're taking your calls
aaa 825-5225-825-5225
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means
even if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal remember rules and
restrictions
apply today's question john comes from
annie in indiana
my husband's dream job is to be a
fireman growing up his parents
repeatedly told him he won't make it
and not to try he recently passed two
national tests
but still has the dallas and fears that
he won't make it he doesn't want to hear
his parents say
i told you so what can i do to boost his
confidence so he can pass his next two
tests oh way to go mom and dad
congratulations i can't tell many times
i've heard this on the ken coleman show
where somebody's like i didn't pursue
because mom and dad told me it was a bad
idea
wait a minute mom and dad so what can
you do tell him to do it but john you're
gonna go deeper here
break that down i don't even parents you
do not protect or help your kids
by making them afraid of themselves or
the world
it doesn't help to look at your child
and say you can try you're probably
going to fail
what is that what does that accomplish
that's a parent hedging their own bets
against their kids future potential pain
yeah let me say yeah that's absolutely
right i'll just say it this way
uh you are projecting your own fear onto
your kid
your insecurity yes that if they don't
turn out the way that you want them to
turn out that everybody's going to say
oh margaret and john were bad parents or
they're they they legitimately don't
want my kid their kid to fail because
failure hurts yes with their kid from
all hurts
will give them a perfect child nope
you'll give them a non-resilient
weak scared broken kid that's right
struggle makes your kids strong
failure makes your kids strong that's
where you rise out of the ash like a
phoenix
way to go mom and dad way to go yeah so
annie
dude just like ken said he is
doing it they wouldn't if the fire
department would have picked him up if
he didn't pass his physicals
the fire department would have picked
him up if he couldn't pass his test
which he has
and here's the thing his parents don't
get a vote
yep right yep i'll add one more thing if
he doesn't pursue this i tell him
you're going to resent your parents
don't look back love that moms and dads
when your kid comes to you with a crazy
idea
you can sit down and say hey talk to me
about that let's go talk to someone at
our
at my work that does that job i want to
hear more about this oh let's read a
book together and talk about it
really you want to try that you want to
be a fireman you can't even jog
let's run a 5k together do something
that's going to bring your relationship
together and i'm getting fired up but
i'm sorry
this isn't his fault i can't stand
parents
who squash their kids out of their own
fears yeah now
my kid comes and says i'm going to drop
out of high school and become a
dance star that's not a good idea
as your parent you need to finish high
school right and especially if i've seen
you dancing
it's not happening but there's a
difference between saying hey
i'll take dance with you and saying
you're going to fail
you're never going to make it yeah what
what you know what i'm saying yeah of
course there's a way to coach your kids
through bad ideas other than just
smashing them but i can tell you this
being a fireman's not a bad idea
so let's relax a little bit yeah you're
gonna fail you're gonna fail
yeah look hey to annie's husband
if your parents do say i told you so
just let it roll off doesn't matter
and doing this just so you can show them
is gonna that's gotta that's gonna
exhaust you too don't do it that do it
because you love being a fireman
you wanna help people yeah good for you
yep absolutely
good advice there triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
evansville indiana and that's where
wade joins us wade how can we help
yes sir i got a question for you okay
i'm a cnc machinist primarily meal
operations here in
my local city uh
long story short i lost a pretty high
paying job due to covered last march
but i was lucky enough to land another
job in a cnc
shop and i'm i lacking experience in
lathe operations and during the
interview they told me that
late operations or me getting experience
in late operations was a very
very good possibility but here i am
almost a year later and
i've asked and they've not they've not
even acknowledged
and i was just wondering how to approach
the uh
the bosses about getting that experience
sure when was the last time you asked
and uh there was no acknowledgement i'd
love to know what the timeline looks
like
uh asked about probably two months ago
and did you ask it in in casual
conversation was it in an actual meeting
or did you
ask in the form of maybe an email say
hey i'd like to meet about it and
nothing has been
reciprocated i talked to
my supervisor about it and he said i'll
get you on one
when i can and i'm you know i'm pretty
good at meal operations i've been doing
it for eight years
so okay well i think you should follow
up because because the the face-to-face
conversation was i'm gonna get you on
when i can
and i think you follow up and go hey
last time we met you said you'd get me
on when you can
and i'm really grateful for that i'm
really excited about it just checking
back in just checking in to see
if there's anything that i can do to
help the timeline uh and i'm assuming
it's not and then and then
what are you looking at maybe ask for a
little bit more detail
as to what determines when he can
hey so let me ask you this wade
let's say he comes to you and says hey
we thought it was gonna happen it's not
gonna
um we need you where you are that's
that's where we see for the next two to
three to five years is where we're gonna
need you
um does that change your desire to keep
working there
oh absolutely i've actually had an
interview and uh i had to
that's where i had it i had to tell i
had to tell them that i didn't have
lathe experience and i'm pretty sure i'm
not going to get the job and it's
a higher paying job okay
so it may be something that you ask hey
can i go practice the lathe on a
saturday can i come up here on a sunday
and use it i just want to get some
skills and
um i'm willing to come stay after hours
to learn how to do this
but how can you work around and get that
experience and it may be that your boss
knows that once you get that experience
you're gonna be out the door right so
there's a hundred different reasons yep
that's right but i'm glad i was gonna
ask you what your
or what statement was and you answered
it for me you're already putting your
application out there you're already
trying to find other places that's right
and and listen
this is the indicator yeah because
you've been told yes once i'm going to
try
if they keep kicking the can down the
road it never feels good
yeah but the good news of that is it's
the sign
yeah and it's time to go don't let that
can kicking
don't invent stories and plant them into
your boss's head don't invent stories
and plan to
just be a person of gratitude be
gracious and then go find another job
right i mean that's what you can do you
can get angry and bitter and they won't
let
cool they they they spoke and they said
what it's going to be and i'm going to
make another decision for me and my
family yeah right
and there is something about that though
the psychology of it you got it you got
to own it it's okay to go man this feels
like rejection
and it feels personal sometimes it is
because we know a lot about healthy
leadership versus unhealthy leadership
but other times it's not personal right
it really isn't
there's it's called fundamental
attribution here when i get into
somebody else's head
and determine why they did what they did
oh right we do that with
voters all the time politicians oh he
didn't put me on the lathe
because he knows i'm better than him
right and he's just trying to keep me
down
i see it and then when you think that
you start seeing it everywhere all the
evidence appears
yeah he doesn't open the door for you
and you're like exactly and that guy
didn't open the door for you because
he's got to go to the bathroom
he's not thinking about you right right
and so i want we do with our spouses we
do with our friends
get out of other people's heads right
just look at the data before you
he said hey we're going to try it's been
six months it's not happening yeah
assume he tried and it's not gonna work
then i'm gonna go take my
my my skill set elsewhere and here's why
what you said john is powerful because
we make it about us a hundred percent
but it doesn't matter
whether it's about us or not but still
we need to move on because i'm looking
at regardless
that's right yeah and if you go let them
know hey i'm moving on because i want to
do lathe work and i've got the
experience and so i appreciate you guys
help then you can you can leave your
heart
you're gonna sleep at night your your
heart rate's gonna be lower
your life you're gonna be healthier just
going about your day man that's it right
yeah yeah just know this is your sign
there's a
there's some country comedian or
somebody that's got a whole uh here's
your side yeah
here's your son billingval built yeah
that's kind of the deal
there's your sign that's right and and
we don't like those signs
no we don't oh we get so fired up so we
just got to make sure that look it's not
personal even if it is personal it
doesn't matter
because you're moving on moving on
anyway yeah it's tough i get to decide
that guy cuts me off on the highway i
get to decide
is he on the way to the er that's good
or is he just doing it to be me
right all right please decide to stay
with us more coming up here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues thrilled to
have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloney
and we are taking your phone calls
aaa 825-5225 and ken i got some big news
our famous
ten dollar sale is here oh boy now you
can learn how to make
faster and real progress with your money
with your job your mental health when
you check out our famous ten dollar sale
save up to sixty percent on over 40
best-selling books and budgeting tools
like the total money makeover
redefining anxiety proximity principle
all of them plus
they make for great gifts for graduates
for people changing jobs moving anything
you can think of they make great gifts
shop our 10 sale at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com
and that's not all we got a gift for you
too
you can also enter to win our ramsey
cash giveaway
we're giving away five hundred dollars
cash every week and a grand prize of
five
thousand dollars cash enter daily for
extra chances to win
no purchase necessary you got to be 18
to do this text
cash to 33789 to enter our giveaway
that's cash to 33789
all right good stuff there the phone
number to jump in triple eight eight
two five five two two five we'd love to
hear from you let's go to ann arbor
michigan where kelly is on the line
kelly how can we help
hi um i'm calling today because
um i've been past baby step three but i
feel like i keep on
spending babysit free on emergencies
like for example our windows wouldn't
shut
in the winter in michigan and so we had
to buy new windows and then we
built up baby steps three and then our
fridge died and now we're back up
and we're investing and we're putting
money towards our kids college
but we need to get a new car because our
car is dying and we also
are going to be having more kids soon
and we need more space
and so i don't know if i'm supposed to
be using like all of baby step three to
help
purchase that vehicle or if it's okay to
take a small loan
or or do i even stop like investing in
college and investing in our investments
in order to purchase a car okay well
let's address the one thing we're not
going to do and that's get a loan
we don't want you to get a loan for the
car because you've got you've got
somewhere with all here you know what to
do and how to do it
um how how much are you uh in a deficit
with your
uh your emergency fund right now
right now we have our emergency so it is
back to full
yeah but then like i said we're falling
like we have this purchase we have to
make again
you know right how much how much do you
want to purchase
the car for we were hoping to get
a minivan that was newer um and most of
those are more than like nine
grand and that's about how much we have
in our emergency fund is nine grand
and so we're just trying to figure out
should we use all of the emergency fund
um because we're planning on like having
a baby in about 10 months you know
and so well the emergency fund the
emergency fund is for an emergency
what's your current car that you're
saying you're kind of predicting it's
death but
we don't really know if that's true is
that correct tell us how bad this
current car is that you're trying to
replace
so right now i need some work done the
ac doesn't work
um the struts are gone um they said
there was going to be at least like a
grand like 800 grand to get it
working again like not working again but
running safely
and our car is worth about two grand so
it's kind of like
getting like put another grand into it
or sell it
for two great you know we're we don't
really know what to do
like should we keep going with this car
it only eats like really five people
comfortably but with like a baby carrier
that's not that comfortable so
we drove around my kid my wife drove our
son
and i drove to in a corolla for several
years and i'm a big guy
we made it work and i know that's not
what any new mom wants to hear
i know that's not what you want to have
this big fancy
i get that um but that one thousand
dollars against a two thousand dollar
car it feels like a quote unquote bad
investment we're throwing bad money away
but when that instead of that 1 000
expense
if you turn around and loop that into a
17 000 car loan
you've had a net negative right and i
know it's frustrating
here's what i'm going to do if i'm your
husband um i'm going to work
berserker for 10 months yup part of i'm
going to put all that nervous new dad
energy
into extra jobs running around like
bananas i'm going to
drive for uber i'm going to deliver
peaches i'm doing whatever i got to do
and i'm going to make it a 10-month goal
that i can
add that money into whatever money y'all
have saved for a new car so that i can
get a van
and if you don't if you end up having to
buy a five or ten thousand dollar car
it's not going to be the end of the
world yeah it's just not i agree
that's the other option kelly is does it
have to be a nine thousand dollar
minivan you know
but if for me i'd spend a thousand
dollars on on fixing
the current car you guys have
replenished your emergency fund multiple
times
so you've got a success track record
here you can save money in your house
and
here's what i want to acknowledge it's
so frustrating oh yeah
oh it's a beating yeah but you guys
could save up the nine grand what can
you do what can you sell
you know to come up with the nine grand
after you fix the current car for
for a thousand right and you replace
that money in the emergency fund and you
come up to nine grand you get the thing
and the baby's happy and the baby never
even knew
but here's one thing you've proven
yourself and i hate to twist your words
on you but are you ready
here's what you've proven to yourself
things are gonna happen
you're gonna need that emergency fund
and so by
by buying windows and then getting the
emergency fund back up fixing the next
thing getting emergency fund back
up it's annoying and frustrating but the
emergency fund is working
and to then take it to buy a car with it
you know what's gonna happen next
your heater is gonna quit right some
your roof's gonna have a hole in it and
now you're gonna have to go take out a
big loan and now you're
back down the hill yeah right so hang
hang
in there that's right hang in there
you've proven to yourself did i use any
of it
i wouldn't use any of the emergency
funds or no if you have a new baby on
the way i want that emergency fund
between four and five and six months so
any money on top of that
should go into a separate account that
is going to be your
car purchase fund yeah the only
emergency but the answer is no you don't
use your emergency fund to buy a car you
use your emergency fund to fix the
current car for a thousand bucks
right and then you save that money and
you replenish it and i know it's so fr
you you were hoping we were going to say
hey it's your first baby go get that van
yeah go get that van i i know the
frustration of putting money into an
older car oh i do too
i mean you want to talk about it's
always not fun to use the emergency fund
but when you're using it on an older car
you're like you've got to be kidding me
yes
yes but i have to remind myself big
picture that's that
is what you always come back to and i
don't want my kid if i can
if i can help it you guys have worked
too hard to get out of debt don't bring
a brand new baby into that stress
right you guys have just worked too hard
you've worked too hard yeah
and she's got her right and i one of the
things we we mentioned briefly but
this is something i've learned because
i'm i'm looking at you know
cheap cars and i i mean cheap in all
caps yes me too because i got a 15 year
old that's going to be 16 in november
you know what i mean and i'm going yes
i mean if i could find a fred flintstone
car for him yes
that's what i would give him because you
know if he can wreck that you know you
know i don't want the bad things to
happen but the point is
right it is what it is the 9 000
that's pretty nice do you know how many
nice vehicles i mean like
not garbage absolutely highly functional
vehicles
are in the five to seven range
over the internet that's right and what
one of the funniest slash
i've got pride in the wrong places okay
so hear me say that
but when i bought this sixteen thousand
dollar truck off a used lot yes i don't
know how old it is
my son climbed into it and he looked
around and he looked at me
and said dad are we rich
and because of how bad my other car had
been i get it and i looked at her and
said
yes son you know what i mean i was like
you've got no idea yeah but he really
was like
what's up now and it was an 06 i mean it
was something well it was probably the
new car smell spray
it i did i waxed it with a new
again the point is not to drive crummy
cars right dave and i've had this
conversation over and over and over
um it's not that's not the point
the point is to drive cars within your
overall budget that's right
yeah and it's not fun it's the worst and
the worst is
we we live in a world where everybody's
driving around a car that they can't
even afford
yes and you will and you're looking at
them and you're going man that car looks
nice i'd like to drive that
and i don't have any debt i've got a
good job and this is a car i'm driving
oh yeah not that i didn't think that on
the way to work this morning right right
but it's like
right nope i'm gonna keep doing it right
i'm gonna keep doing it right i'm gonna
have that magic word of my patience yeah
and your baby's gonna love you anyway
whether it's in a corolla or one of them
those brand new those new plymouth
minivans oh
it's crazy rad but that babies just need
to be in the car seat that's right
you know so you got this you guys kelly
have done a great job
so dealing with life coming at you keep
doing it the way you've been doing it
don't get distracted
you got this and congratulations yes on
the baby
all right don't move more ramsay show
coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr
john deloney thrilled to have you with
us triple 825-5225
is the phone number today's scripture of
the day colossians 4 6
let your conversation be always full of
grace seasoned with salt
so that you may know how to answer
everyone
and our quote today comes from john
maxwell a leader is great not because of
his or her power
but because of his or her ability to
empower
others triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to jump in
let's go to indianapolis indiana where
phil
joins us phil how can we help
hey guys uh thanks for taking my call
it's great to speak with you
um my wife and i are considering making
a fairly large purchase
and i wanted to just basically get a
third opinion
from you guys based on where we are in
the baby steps
okay where are you in the baby steps
well um we are i believe at
a baby step six um
we are debt-free with the exception of
our house okay
uh we have a fairly uh overfunded
emergency and fund at this point
honestly
due to some extenuating circumstances
but uh
we do have about 175 000 in an emergency
fund
what's the circumstances um
i was involved in an accident okay that
uh resulted in a settlement that um
padded that a little bit and it's just
uh basically gone
unallocated up to this point hanging out
there okay tell us tell us how much
overage you have so we know what that
number
um six months of expenses for us
probably looks somewhere in the
neighborhood of about
uh forty thousand dollars so it's
way way over right yes sir okay
all right so you got a 130 grand just
just parked there yeah
how much you got left on your mortgage
man it's a blessing but at the same time
it's a little bit
of overwhelming yes that's right how
much you get left on your mortgage
um so our mortgage is the balance is
about
250. okay and we are contributing a
little extra to that
okay so what's your question well uh
basically the purchase that we're
looking to make
it is a luxury purchase if you will my
wife and i have
kind of dreamed for a long time of
owning an rv um we have two young
children
and the the price tag on that is around
30 000
and like i said at the outset kind of
just looking for
a green light if you will um because you
know my wife and i we just
i'm the budget the nerd the conservative
and my wife is more of the free spirit
and i guess it's just kind of uh
dude dude uh how about not a green light
how about the old green flag of the
nascar race i'm waving my arm
i mean 30 000 to buy an rv and you still
have
overages you would like to call 100
grand 100 extra in your emergency fund
that you
could put on that house they say yeah
i'm good that's probably
i'm good with that yeah there's probably
a lot of people rolling their eyes at me
no no no don't worry about all those
people yeah they don't get a vote
yeah if you if you go buy that 30 000 rv
today with cash
and that doesn't mean you have to then
buy a 70 000 truck to pull it right
you've got all that down
and you go take that other 100 grand and
tomorrow morning or monday morning you
go
put that against your mortgage to where
your mortgage only 150 grand on the left
then man i say hi five and stop by
nashville and see us on your way on your
first trip yeah
come take a picture in front of the
building
listen man i've been down to see you
guys once before but i'd love to come
back
bring the rv john and i'll come in and
have a cookie i will not but
really no i probably would yeah of
course you i love rvs
yeah i think this is great
congratulations you guys have done the
hard work
uh keep walking this thing out i mean
that you know
you guys yes do this celebrate and you
know this
once you have 150 grand left on your
house man it's pretty easy to
make eye contact with your wife decide
you're going to go gazelle intense for
just a short season and knock that
sucker out too right
yeah that's the dream that's awesome
phil way to go
you guys deserve this you have the cash
this is not a silly
crazy vain whatever word that you've
been putting in your head this is okay
yeah you got a hundred thousand extra
dollars good for you yeah
let's go to chicago next where jason
joins us jason how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
i am
uh i'm currently debt free outside of my
mortgage and
in about two months i will have
enough stock non-retirement stocks saved
up
that i can sell and actually pay off my
mortgage
which in my head sounds like a great
idea to get out from under this
and so i'm just calling to get some
advice so are these just single stocks
floating out there that you've just
purchased over time
yeah basically uh you know through my
own company
i get to purchase the company i work for
fantastic
and then you but you have an external
401 or external retirement program
that's separate than this
yes and i'm maxing that out uh and i max
it out every single year
okay actually i get money back every
year good for you terrible you know you
said something
you said something interesting jason and
i could be reading into this but you
said in my head
sounds like the right thing to do and
i'm wondering is there somebody else
that has a different voice in their head
that's involved in this or is that just
the way you said it
no no i i my wife is completely on board
as well and okay good both
uh you know we've been rambling fans and
and have gotten
you know this far um you know it's the
io270
on my house and literally i'll
have the stock to do that um and then
be debt-free and then the idea would be
to kind of start building that back up
again but
you know i don't know how much is the
house worth
right now uh probably 690.
dude what are the what are the taxes
against those stocks
stock sale um i
you know i would have to i would have to
run the numbers on it um
that's something david left with his
head yeah that's right that's a good
point because i think i think
we were assuming i know i incorrectly
assumed that you had run the math on if
you're going to cash those stocks out
you got to know what your tax hit is on
that so
if you're but yeah single stock selling
brother don't touch your retirement yeah
but sell the single stocks be debt free
in your house and then come down here
nashville
and scream it as loud as you can here on
the debt free stage brother yeah
absolutely love it yeah congratulations
man
that's fantastic i mean you just think
about that you know because you got some
people i know are going oh
that stock obviously this guy's done you
know he's done pretty well here
but wait a second there's no guarantee
those stocks are going to hold that
especially internal circulating
companies stocks
right my mom worked for this little
company for several years called enron
yes oh yeah she worked for another
little company called deloitte and twos
they loved
the internal circulation boy isn't that
the truth you know enron was
about to sure a thing as there was it
was the surest and you want to talk
about it didn't exist
quick yeah it just evaporated didn't
exist right and uh so but the difference
is they're debt-free
have a nearly seven hundred thousand
dollar house yeah paid for
and more importantly i want everybody
here saying
you're not cashing out retirement no
we're not
i've been guilty of that of looking at
it and saying
man i'd love to have that cash i want to
go ahead and i think this is the top of
the market or whatever not since i
thought i'd sure
and um we're not what we're saying but
yeah you got these floating stocks out
there
yeah cash them out get rid of them pay
your house off and we're going to be
good to go
so ken um real quick
you've got a big event coming up tell us
about it yeah the get hired event is uh
april the 27th eight eastern seven
central it's gonna be a live stream
event so you can get it anywhere you've
got an internet connection
and a device ticket start at just twenty
dollars you can text the word hired at
three three seven eight nine and what
we're gonna do in that night
is we're gonna break down the three
key things you've got to do to beat the
competition because
at the end of the day with the way that
artificial intelligence is being used
when you submit a resume there's things
you've got to do
on the resume just to get noticed
because they're doing keyword search and
things like that
and then you've got to go the human
route which is what i teach
which is always going to be artificial
intelligence john because if i got a
connection
it's over and somebody's willing to walk
my resume in even though i had to submit
it online they went hey john let me tell
you about this guy i know
i think you ought to consider him that's
it i've known him this long that's the
game changer that is
and every job of my life absolutely true
so we're going to go into that kind of
detail it's going to be a lot of fun uh
again you can get your tickets starting
at just twenty dollars
text the word hired to three three seven
hey and you've got some cool stuff
planned for this this is
not just gonna be oh hey ken coleman
like in one of those really short faces
in front of a zoom call you've got a
whole bunch of stuff going on right yeah
it's gonna be a lot of fun we're gonna
do some live q and a so you hear real
people's questions as we begin to walk
through what they're dealing with yeah
and how they overcome it so it's gonna
be a lot of fun thanks for bringing that
up
dr john delay make sure you all check
out the dr john daloni show on the
ramsey
solutions network it's a great great
podcast also on youtube blowing up
hey john thanks for hanging with me you
too man always fun i want to thank our
producer
james childs and our associate producer
and call screener kelly daniel and you
america thank you for listening this has
been the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you